i want to talk this morning about one
particular uh item on our agenda which
has been uh raised by our constituents
month in month out for years and that is
the site of people crossing the channel
in unseaworthy vessels risking their
lives at the uh the instigation of
criminal gangs who are getting away uh
with uh in in some cases uh i think uh
uh
manslaughter if not murder in what
they're they're doing in taking people
across the channel in patently
unsea-worthy vessels uh we have had to
stop it it's been extremely difficult to
find a way of doing it that is humane it
is not reasonable to try to turn boats
around at sea in the uh english channel
those waters are very dangerous uh we we
we've had to work within uh the scope of
uh of common humanity and and compassion
that's the right thing to do but we have
to interrupt the business model of the
gangs and what we see now is uh our
policy uh the
economic and migration partnership with
rwanda
that we have uh engaged upon and now
under a huge amount of attack and not
least from uh from from lawyers who are
finding way to to underground i love
lawyers i mean many people around this
table uh are lawyers uh but uh but there
are even me there are even but let me
put it this way my dear friends and
colleagues there are even more people
around this table uh whose answer who
aren't lawyers
[Music]
who are engineers but whose ancestors
whose immediate ancestors came to this
country uh to seek a new life here many
of many of us uh whose ancestors came in
fear of their lives and fleeing
persecution and this is a government
really unlike many others in uh in the
way that we we represent that tradition
of this country that tradition of
welcoming people that tradition of
allowing talent to come to this country
and what is happening uh with the
attempt to undermine the rwanda policy
is that they are i'm afraid uh
undermining everything that we're trying
to do to support safe and legal routes
for people to come to the uk and to
oppose the illegal and dangerous routes
that is what we are trying to do that is
the essence of of our policy
and i think that
what the criminal gangs are doing and
what the uh those who effectively are
abetting the work of the criminal gangs
are doing is undermining people's
confidence in the safe and legal system
undermining people's general acceptance
of of immigration so my message to
everybody today is that we are not going
to be in any way uh deterred or abashed
by
some of the criticism that is being
directed upon this policy uh some of it
from slightly unexpected uh quarters uh
we are going to get on and and deliver
and the objective the objective is to
ensure that we make that clear
distinction that i think everybody can
see is fair and reasonable between legal
immigration to this country by safe and
legal routes which we support and uphold
and protect because we all understand
the benefits that it brings and
distinguishing that from dangerous and
illegal cross-channel migration which we
intend to stop